okay top five I'm going to use that
single pivot point lately I've been
turning to this side the inside this
time I've been in charge of the young
side so cool and on that single pivot
point I can turn this way again I don't
want my line of gravity between my two
feet and I walk around like that
I'm going to move my body off the line
at the top hips turn and I go single -
white turn and I know single pivot
point there's no weight on that foot
turn boom a night though and this sort
of technique is together so single pivot
point turn boom
Danny the speed and the completion the
yeni Turner single pivot point
single pivot point turns in turn single
pivot point both T turn
hey let's try just a pet peeve around
see how close that sword into my body
it happens from unconsciousness and it
happens from it's no contest if he
pushes on me right see my hand came into
me right so all things it maintains your
pressure by moving my body okay and then
I would do my projection from the elbow
okay but all things beautiful you're
going to share right I keep the distance
so this is a form so it's an idealized
situation so disordered is to stay at
45-degree angle that you've been using
the entire time so for example after
this ski don't go like this
after this ski boom boom so when we come
around you get to pick where you are so
I'm gonna come in keep that 45 boom in
pop then the other way same thing keep
the 45 boom boom boom
okay let's try close
he's got four Spectre Joey
No so you can see that it is a young
line okay especially if I keep my line
of gravity inside I can't get around
okay so we can use this to show
something else okay so as I'm doing the
form I am I'm here and I'm gonna move
that force vector to there do you see
that that's what the first ship does
when you when you're here like this and
you don't do that it just you can push
off my logic tracker so I'm going to
shift my weight and then turn around
you'll feel that boom and then this
becomes my pivot point here you see I
can I can't get there if I do it like
that so shift Brown new ground turn
around
so I'm grounded on the back foot shift
to the front foot and then rotate around
that spot so what I'm doing is taking
away this contest do you see how you did
that so I moved then I'm gonna turn
around I'm not going here okay oh
this is your training yes get rid of the
contention point go forward okay let's
try it okay so we're looking at this
line of gravity we're looking at this
line of gravity that's between his two
feet
it is currently between his two feet
right now okay and in the form he should
be on the back foot at this point but
this is what's common this is this is
what Aikido is for most of us okay so
I'm now tasked in the midst of pressure
to go forward into it this is going to
be impossible unless I learn how to
deconstruct the contest okay so we're
gonna see because as he moves and he
tries to force his way into the contest
the pressure at the contest moves his
line of gravity and he can't come around
try it try your best you see okay so
he's trying to get off of that so we're
gonna see this again okay go ahead you
can shift alright now I'm going to tell
you if he was single point pivot the
back
would be able to slide back and forth as
we've demonstrated many times but he's
he's still not single point pivoting he
still got a two-point stance okay and so
as he goes around go it's gonna this
line of Bradley's gonna get moved okay
now again let's say he was powerful
enough because it's still a contest is
still force versus force
so if Sean's force can override
Ronan's force you see and Rodan who's
backwards is like oh it worked
but it did not because Ronin did not
come falling into the void and so
there's no Kazushi that's actually
happening all that's happened is that
the contest has moved towards Sean's
right okay so here we go this is because
you have a young booth if they've been
young moves are easy but it's a young
culture and they're supposed to be again
in the midst this job you see that so
again most Aikido he's he's here he's
pushy and we were wanting to like this
well of course you wanted to do
that right but that's not sophisticated
this is more sophisticated is I'm going
to figure out how to get rid of that
point this point he's pushing is first I
start with Tokyo grounding so we're
gonna stay here all day
it's he's just
into the back way okay instead of a gear
double weighted and the line of gravity
is between my base and he is taking me
in the shukaku
do you guys see that so we're here and a
five double awaited you won't even let
him get on there okay
but as he goes to push boom you see and
I put it on this leg and this legs not
doing any this legs not doing it okay
now I'm gonna move it and as to take
this leg off it can't just be a matter
of on here because pressure actually
increased in it you see it's it's in
here
release release so that's going to be
our drill now because what I find is you
become enamored by the throw
so you're here that's not a cheetah that
doesn't work either
I need him to fall into the void so even
with the yard move there's a void so are
my drill now is not going to be the
throw it's going to see how much Boyd I
create which is going to be measured by
how much he falls into it okay that's my
goal
don't throw up just take this away with
a count of five okay yes this is taking
it away but that's I have five
here
Oh
and I'm gonna give you a clue you can't
do count five with emotional tension it
what it doesn't work you have to kind of
accept release
maybe you've been ignored these are
applying pointers these are imagination
pointers once you figure out what it is
I can think about the hardest thing and
it's okay but in the beginning release
accept welcome any thought that gets you
to relax a little bit and just do the
food okay
try everything this is not it and you're
gonna do this to you see that is
destruction
you won't be able to do this problem
okay so I'm not talking keep the
structure okay let's go we're not here
and I single point pivot this shoulder
actually goes that way when I double
point pivot this shoulder goes that way
so again double-double point pivot
lighting drivers between my feet I
wouldn't get there because they'd be
moving it but let's assume I did watch
the shoulder rotation okay it's going to
go this way as I come around come around
until here when I single point pivot I'm
here this shoulder goes back from here
right from the get-go it's going that
way you think so
we're here and you guys see is his hands
let's just let's assume I could get
there okay so I'm still there's still
pressure you can see let's say I'm
strong enough he's pushing you see he's
not falling in yet he's not falling in
yet he's not falling in yet he's not
falling in yet because my shoulder has
not yet yielded it's not calling in yet
now my shoulders starting to go back not
until then can you just slow it down
when I go here and I started to turn the
shoulders already going by so you got to
watch that even though you you might be
strong enough you not doing the heart
okay this shoulder back needed
immediately so keep that in mind and
you're taking keep that in mind right
and the way that you get to the mind is
usually what happens is your head will
see I he had to readjust his foot you
see that and that gave me the space I
need to keep keep to one constant
pressure like an aggressor would have
don't keep adjusting your perspective
okay okay so he was pushing me right
and I yielded everyone would go okay
yeah he's not contesting I'm doing the
same thing I'm doing the same thing this
is still guilty he's pushing and I'm not
contested I don't need you create
distance to not contest
I just don't Yong Yong I don't push on
what's pushing on me
I don't pull on let's pull it on me okay
so the same thing goes when I go to the
technique that's going to be and pull on
the pole okay I can still take his
balance by continually not contesting
using the same thing as we go around
here back around here don't pull his
bottoms and I keep reconciling that Yong
Yong by going around it perpetually
going around it just like this
[Music]
I'll show you a Yong Yong sorry I'll
show you a Yong Yong it looks like oh
that's Marshall you guys I go ah I know
I'm not doing that just continually
he'll be forced to have it feels like
Jesus that was all his energy wasn't my
energy okay
just like when he goes to push he feels
his huh but I
he doesn't feel me did I don't feel me
and I should say he feels his aggression
so he's feeling his aggression and the
drug too as they come around
he doesn't feel me
[Music]
Thanks I can be very relaxed do the same
technique and still have a lie energy
for the stroke but I've been contest
once okay let's go back to the throw so
the opening we're using is we count 5
opening but the principles were using
are still for the throw are still to
count 5 principles
ok so I'm going to yield the shoulder
and now I'm here
you see where I'm on the side of his
head not hooking I'm on the side of the
face so we're going to show the physics
involved okay so if I stay here right
keep going I can't even do this throw
this he's going to keep going ok
but which is why when you stay here you
go like that you see so that's the only
way but now this is a class this is not
the end reconciliation D contestation so
I'm here so if we come back I'm leaving
ok you can hear some smokey after so
doubt if I were strong enough I can
generate enough force you will create a
topsy-turvy attack but it's not the
heart there's the ceiling to it and it's
much lower than you think it is a
mechanical ceiling so what I'm doing is
something different just like I'm doing
something different I'm not one like
this I'm actually even unbuttoned
forward I'm moving that shoulder bop
okay so I'm just here ok now I have to
figure out how to get that friction Oh
as he starts to go we're gonna do a
slower it's got
okay I feel it I'm going to start
getting his head to go like this you
make his hand to photograph because
that's the Kazushi pattern you see it
okay so I'm with him
now if I stay here he's gonna come up
again you see that yo he's falling this
way and I yield that way you see no here
like that and now his momentum does the
rest
I don't do it his legs go out cuz he's
going forward so I'm gonna leave his
head here and his feet keep walking and
you go to that line and broccoli is
gonna fall outside the base of support
you see that so I'm not going around
whoa again you see my hand go down and
you think that's where the throw is but
that's not where the throwing that's
just the I can't even I'm following him
down come around arm around wall this
way
around on the faster he goes the smaller
bike movement can be the greater that
engagement when you do the other way the
faster he goes with the stronger he goes
the more classical hobbies of my
mechanical baggage this goes away okay
so you go he goes far and it's very
quick very quick it's just a tilt and
then the legs keep going that's all I'm
doing
okay let's try to so let's go back he's
pushing I am you being to that
if I stay here what's gonna happen you
you're wondering how do I get the tilt
well there is a contest station and what
I'm doing is letting off pressure to
keep the friction to get the tilt you
see I don't have to hook him to get the
tilt it's just pressure I feel push in
to create the friction move that
pressure I now start to use it to turn
him I don't look up
because hooking them is going to be the
bull pull it's really no different when
you do taking even avi on this hand
don't you don't even grab the taller his
energy was going in he's seen energies
going in and that's what I used to turn
them that energy creates a friction here
he goes and I taking it off
so he goes and the friction we keeps
going and I just keep taking it all so
that I can keep it turning now and then
I have that tilt you see
so that is why is Deakin testing this
bike he's here he's pushing I am taking
pressure off with the yield do you see
the same exact thing same exacting here
the pressure is taking the yield boom oh
there we are
and I just keep incremental e taking it
off till I get
[Music]
you'll see that this is different okay
Charlie